no Dire Straits for Magnus he's on the
ropes I don't even I don't even know
what to recommend here Queen C1 rookie
two
it's insane I I can't find a move Hikaru
is doing it he's got 15 seconds to find
a move and Magnus closes his eyes and
goes all in and oh my God
Rook a two he missed it oh my goodness
work takes me six again Rook takes P6
and it's over
rotations oh my goodness he still has
something maybe
both Rooks are sacrificed
this might be winning by the way but he
only needs a draw as the match clock
expires and Hikaru is exasperated oh my
gosh I'm on Hikaru it's based mate and
it's a draw by agreement and it's the
match he offers a draw a gentleman's
draw and I mean what a finish it
literally comes down to the last game
and look at the smile on even hikaru's
face these guys are just two Titans two
Champions going out one another you
cannot script this any better